Wilbur and Orville Wright did everything
together they started a local newspaper
together opened up a bike shop together
and they invented the first airplane
together they were so in sync that
Wilbur said they thought together but
they also fought together they argued a
lot the bickering would often start at
breakfast carry on through lunch and
continue past dinner once a quarrel
became so intense that their sister
Catherine cried out if you don't stop
arguing I'll leave home standing up for
themselves was encouraged in their
childhood their father Milton Wright was
a bishop but he included books by
atheists and agnostics in his library
and encouraged his children to read and
debate them debating helped them develop
the courage to fight for their ideas if
they hadn't the airplane might never
have been invented in the early days of
Aviation the very idea of human flight
was considered Impossible The Washington
Post declared at the turn of the 20th
century it is a fact that man can't fly
many attempted controlled flight but
none had succeeded in 1896 German
Aviator Oto lantal lost his life when he
lost control of his glider due to a
sudden gust of wind his technique of
adjusting the machine's center of
gravity by shifting his body proved
impractical and dangerous despite no
college education or Technical Training
the wght brothers dared to dream of
flight with Orville saying we could not
understand that there was anything about
a bird that would enable it fly that
could not be built on a larger scale and
used by man one of their most intense
arguments had to do with the design of
the propeller in the early 20th century
there were no existing models most of
what they knew came from their knowledge
of boats but a propeller design for the
water didn't work efficiently in the air
they needed a narrower Blade with a
higher speed with no existing designs to
work from they had to invent the
propeller themselves they argued over
the propeller's speed the precise angle
at which the blades strike the air the
velocity of their flying machine and how
air flow around the propeller blades
affects aerodynamics all of these
elements were deeply interconnected and
challenged them to engineer the ideal
propeller Wilbur the older brother was
highly disagreeable and didn't care much
about what other people thought of him
Orville on the other hand was gentle and
sensitive to criticism but wasn't afraid
to punch back when it came to his older
brother Wilbur even exclaimed he's such
a good scrapper author John McMahon who
wrote a book about the WR Brothers
described their intense debates this way
their low staccato voices sounded like
muffled machine guns in the low
ceilinged living room of their home and
in the little bedroom upstairs where
they continued to hurl angles signs
cosiness and tangents at each other
through the thin partitions sometimes
these debates escalated into shouting
matches their bike mechanic Charlie
Taylor who helped build the engines for
their planes observed they'd shout at
each other something terrible I don't
think they really got mad but they sure
got awfully hot yet they never attacked
each other personally but rather focused
on challenging each other's viewpoints
they'd even find themselves persuing
each other and then both changing their
minds Orville recalled we would discover
that we were as far from agreement as
when we started but that both had
changed to the other's original position
in the discussion after months of debate
the R Brothers finally understood that a
propeller works like a rotating Wing
when the propellers Spin and push air
backward it creates a force called
thrust which pushes the airplane forward
this is based on Newton's third law of
motion which says that for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
they eventually figured out that the
plane needed not one propeller but two
spinning in opposite directions the
spinning of one would balance out the
other making the plane easier to control
they made the propellers out of wood
cutting them to the right size and shape
using a hatchet and drop shave they then
decided to put them to the test at Kitty
Hawk a small fishing Village in North
Carolina known for its strong winds when
they had to decide who would attempt the
first flight on December 14 1903 they
avoided another argument in this case by
tossing a coin Wilbur won but he lost
the chance to be the first to fly
successfully when he over steered
causing the aircraft to climb too
steeply stall and dive into the sand
after repairing their flyer they made a
second attempt 3 days later
with Orville in the pilot seat the flyer
stayed in the air for 12 seconds
traveling 120 ft or 37 M when Orville
was later asked if he was scared he
responded scared there wasn't time they
flew four times that day the fourth and
final attempt this time with Wilbur at
the controls was the best flight lasting
59 seconds and covering 852 ft or 260 M
they had taught the world that humans
could fly but they didn't really
celebrate for them it was business as
usual their mechanic Charlie Taylor
captured their understated reaction
perfectly I know I thought it was pretty
nice that they had done what they set
out to do and I was glad to hear that
the motor ran all right but I don't
remember doing any jig steps the boys
were always so matter of fact about
things even when they got home there was
no special celebration in the shop of
course they were pleased with the
flights but their first word with me as
I remember was about the motor being
damaged they were always thinking of the
next thing to do just as their arguments
were never about personally attacking
each other but about making their planes
better they didn't go for a big
celebration but instead focused on
improving their aircraft now they had to
prove they could fully control their
plane by turning and flying longer
distances as their flights up to then
were short and in a straight line
luckily the owner of a cow pasture a few
miles outside of their hometown of
Dayton Ohio kindly let them fly there so
they didn't have to make the long trk to
kitta
in 1904 and 1905 the R Brothers made
about 150 flights one lasted 39 minutes
covering 24 1/2 mil or 39 km during
which Wilbur circled the field 29 times
when it was time to show the world their
invention the French Aviator Leon deange
summed up the superiority of the right
flying machine this way n Batu meaning
we are beaten their rigorous debates
propelled the R Brothers to conquer the
skies as Wilbur once said discussion
brings out new ways of looking at things
if the right Brothers hadn't argued so
much they would have never pushed each
other to try new things and somebody
else may have ended up in the history
books their dedication in knowledge of
math and physics led to the world's
first functional airplane if you've been
inspired to build a strong foundation in
stem brilliant is a great resource to
learn math science computer science and
data science interactively
whether you're starting with the basics
in math or tackling more advanced
problems brilliant guides you every step
of the way many of their interactive
courses are designed to tackle real
world challenges take brilliant's new
thinking en code course which gets you
designing simple programs to solve real
world problems like creating a
navigation app you can try out brilliant
for free for 30 days by signing up with
a custom link in my description
brilliant.org
newthink and if you're one of the first
200 people to sign up with my link
you'll receive 20% off Brilliance
premium subscription which gives you
access to all of their thousands of
offerings thanks for watching for news
thinkink I'm Cindy pal